[Music]
global national with donna friesen
[Music]
it has happened this is ukraine's
capital what seemed unthinkable in the
21st century is now underway a
democratic country has been invaded by
its nuclear-armed neighbor on multiple
fronts people are not safe in their own
homes this apartment building in kharkiv
ukraine's second largest city was struck
killing at least one person ukraine's
president said tonight 137 people have
died 316 others are wounded it is a
full-scale attack forcing ukrainians to
decide whether to flee or to fight
ukraine's president has declared martial
law appealed for blood donations and
says weapons are being given to anyone
who wants to defend the country russia
he says is on a path of evil
at the kremlin this chilling warning
from the russian president to countries
coming to ukraine's defense
[Music]
russia is using fighter jets missiles
ground forces and special forces
attacking from the east the north and
the south targeting both military
infrastructure and major urban centers
including the capital city
this is a deliberate
cold-blooded
and long-planned invasion
despite its litany of lies denials and
disinformation
the kremlin's intentions are clear for
the world to see
putin is the aggressor
putin chose this war and now he and his
country will bear the consequences
president putin launched the greatest
threat to european stability
since world war ii history will judge
president putin
as harshly
as the world condemns him today
today
he cements his place
in the ranks of the reviled european
dictators
good evening and thanks for joining us
many ukrainians are staying to fight
others are fleeing in an attempt to keep
their families safe we have special
coverage tonight beginning with crystal
gomencing at the polish border crystal
donna this is the karchova border
crossing between ukraine and poland
throughout the day we've seen a steady
stream of cars crossing over we've also
seen a large contingent of the polish
army sort of organizing things here
along with border guards now as russia's
invasion intensifies this is one of the
border crossings where we anticipate to
see a large number of ukrainians
crossing over to flee that fighting
from kharkiv
to chuhuyev
to kiev
civilian occupied zones were not spared
by russian missiles the widespread
invasion commencing in the early morning
hours thursday
among key strategic sites targeted
keeves airport reportedly now under the
control of russian forces
bombings too at the other airports and
military sites and ukraine's prime
minister confirms russia now controls
the chernobyl nuclear plant
russian troops unrelenting in their
attacks vladimir putin saying ukraine
needed to be demilitarized
i urge all ukrainian soldiers to
immediately lay down your arms and go
home
but many ukrainians are unwilling to
take orders from the kremlin
i will take my children away and return
we will fight this off ukraine will win
no matter what said one man departing
keefe following the bombings
those willing to stand and fight are
being given the full support of
ukraine's president
we are already handing out weapons and
we hand them out to defend our country
to everyone who wants and has the
capability to defend our sovereignty the
future of ukraine depends on every
citizen
as ukrainians battled russian fighters
by air and land vladimir zelinski urged
his people to stay calm telling them the
military a fraction of the size of
russia's would be victorious if they
stayed united
let's not panic let's do everything that
is needed to support armed forces of
ukraine together we must save ukraine
save democratic world
lithuania and moldova have declared
states of emergency anticipating further
aggression beyond ukraine's borders
putin already warned other nations to
stay on the sidelines or face quote
consequences that you have never
encountered in your history
and even now on the other side of that
border there are multiple battles being
fought at different sites
donna crystal commencing in poland
tonight thank you well ukraine has been
pleading for the world to help and for
swift and hard sanctions against russian
interests to cut it off from the world
now that the attack has begun that is
beginning to happen but is it enough to
stop vladimir putin who has laughed in
the face of past sanctions we'll have
canada's response in just a moment but
we begin with jackson proskow in
washington
the global response to russia has been
swift and sharp putin's aggression
against ukraine will end up costing
russia dearly
economically and strategically
we will make sure that the u.s led the
charge with american sanctions cutting
off russian banks from the global
financial system freezing hundreds of
billions of dollars in russian assets
and barring high-tech exports to russian
companies the only thing that i'm
convinced of is if we don't stop now
he'll be emboldened we'll be imposing
the moves were backed by similar
announcements in london and across
europe these powers will enable us
totally to exclude russian banks from
the uk financial system which is of
course by far the largest in europe all
told countries representing half the
global economy are taking action against
vladimir putin russia won't be able to
do business in dollars pounds euros or
yen according to officials russian
oligarchs the elite who support putin
are being squeezed directly too we don't
need sanctions that bark we need
sanctions that bite and if the sanctions
bite they need to bite in a very
thorough way yet there is division
amongst western allies over how far to
go russia's energy sector has emerged
unscathed higher oil prices would
benefit the kremlin and damage western
economies sanctions we oppose exceed
anything that's ever been done
there's also a deep line in the sand the
u.s and nato insist they will not
intervene militarily in ukraine though
the u.s is sending another 7 000 troops
to bolster nato allies in the region
and cyber attacks against key russian
infrastructure remain an option but the
u.s says only if russia attacks western
interests first
the sanctions announced today have two
purposes one is an immediate blow to
russia the second is a longer-term set
of consequences and one thing that's
still very much on the table tonight our
personal sanctions against vladimir
putin those could be announced in the
coming days
donna all right jackson thank you
canada imposed more sanctions today
targeting members of the russian elite
and major banks with me from ottawa is
canada's foreign affairs minister
melanie jolie madam minister let me ask
you about those sanctions you know the
ukrainian foreign minister has made it
very clear what he thinks needs to
happen he tweeted today i will not be
diplomatic on this everyone who now
doubts whether russia should be banned
from swift which is the international
banking system has to understand that
the blood of innocent ukrainian men
women and children will be on their
hands to
ban russia from swift he is unequivocal
why is that not happening right now
well you know we've said that there
would be extremely strong sanctions
that's what we announced today and we're
doing so at the same time as all our g7
allies so the us the uk the eu and japan
but we've also said and i've also said
donna that we would
be adding sanctions we had already
restricted actually limited completely
the sovereign death of russia so the
capacity of russia to finance itself in
our
within our economy
and we had already
said that we would be making a dealing
ban between canada and the two regions
at the beginning of the week that had
been recognized as independent which is
don esken and luhangs by the putin and
this recognition is completely outraging
what we're doing today is even
more
all the major banks of russia are now
under sanction
we are making sure also that
more than 60 individuals and entities
are sanctioned uh by uh by canada i
understand the sanctions announced today
are more severe than they've ever been
but why hold back others why not
sanction putin himself why not ban
russia from swift
well like i mentioned we will continue
to impose sanctions we will make sure
that we're acting in a coordinated way
we very much know also that canada
doesn't have a huge amount of trade with
russia because of our geography but
because also we had sanctioned uh years
ago when russia invaded crimea 400
individuals and entities
what we want to do though is to make
sure that there's no loophole in this
sanctioned approach
can you see a point where canadian
soldiers would be on the ground in
eastern europe fighting russian forces
well we've decided to reinforce
our participation within nato and
should article five so should a threat
to use of force against a member of the
alliance
be be done by russia well of course we
will make sure to uh react and promptly
that's why i had the chance to be in
contact with secretary general of nato
ian stoltenberg earlier today because
obviously what is at stake right now is
europe's security and when europe's
security is at stake it is also our own
security that is at stake
minister jolie thanks for taking time
with us
thank you thank you donna thank you
mercedes stevenson is with me now from
ottawa mercedes canada and other
countries holding back being as tough as
they could be with sanctions are they
keeping their powder dry what are we and
our allies waiting for
i think a lot of people are wondering
that as we see what looks like a
full-scale invasion in ukraine people
are wondering why not act now there's a
few reasons that may be going into this
calculation the first is political will
of our allies
essentially the g7 nato countries want
to act in lockstep because it's more
powerful but some of those countries
could face significant economic
consequences for action taken including
canada there's also the desire right now
to leave an exit route for vladimir
putin to perhaps fall back and not try
to hold all of ukraine and concerns that
targeting him in particular could lead
to a bit of a trumpian response where if
he's challenged he becomes more
aggressive personally but i did ask
prime minister justin trudeau if
sanctioning vladimir putin is on his
radar this is what he said today
the key thing on sanctions has been
to come forward in a coordinated way
with all our allies and that is the
unity that is
most damaging
to the kremlin uh and to vladimir putin
that uh we are all
unequivocal and united on this
so it sounds like it's potentially on
the table there are more sanctions
coming but they need the buy-in
obviously of all the allies in order to
do that in the meantime there are other
things that can be done as well
including banning russian oil and gas
from canada it is imported here the
prime minister would not commit to that
today and of course the ukrainians are
asking for things they are asking for
things including weapons and support
take a listen to what the ukrainian
charges affairs told me
they need helmets they need tactical
armored jackets they need firearms they
are ready to fight but they need
ammunition they need uh equipment and
then they need arms yes indeed we need
more
so donna whether or not canada decides
to provide more lethal aid remains to be
seen
okay mercedes thanks
neil howard is a canadian journalist in
kiev tonight neil thanks for speaking
with us you know people have known for
weeks that this might happen that russia
might invade now that it's happened what
is it like there
i mean it's very surreal there's no sign
of them yet in the the center of the
city here i mean we're still very early
days russia
the vast majority of russian forces are
not committed yet we heard jets over the
capitol uh about a couple hours ago and
especially west of the capital
at an airfield there russia launched a
wave of paratroopers with through they
sent about 50 attack helicopters and
landed paratroopers at that airfield and
they're they're now trying to establish
that as a forward base to establish an
air bridge uh to bring reinforcements uh
directly to the doorstep of kiev neil it
sounds quiet where you are right now
what are
what do people fear most
i mean i think the people fear that you
know russia will go all the way with
this and yeah and that everything is on
the table i mean the the people fear you
know that they they might just start uh
bombing severely kiev they might start
bombing the the city itself
neil hauer in kiev tonight thanks
what is the point and the power of
economic sanctions that's coming up
the weapon being used against russia
right now is sanctions the idea is to
hit the russian economy and putin's
inner circle cutting off their money
jeff semple looks at the power of
sanctions and whether they'll make any
difference to vladimir putin
as russian forces invaded ukraine
western countries responded with a
different kind of weapon we're living in
a world where the tools of war are
actually economic and trade weapons
canada the us and europe announcing a
slew of sanctions measures that are
tougher than anything we've ever seen
before as far as russia is concerned but
this hedge fund manager and high profile
kremlin critic says the measures still
fall short what is fundamentally
upsetting to vladimir putin is going
after his own money
and what all the sanctions programs so
far missing is going after his own money
putin's own money he says is controlled
by around 50 russian oligarchs whose
assets were left untouched
and even the sanctions targeting
russia's economy are less potent now
than they were after its annexation of
crimea in 2014.
in the seven years since putin has only
furthered russia's foreign reserves and
resilience so it's less dependent on the
us dollar it's less dependent on oil
revenues because the other thing that
it's done is actually pivot to the east
from crude oil to computer chips russia
now does more business with china and
eurasian nations it's also creating its
own international payment system in case
it gets cut off from swift germany and
italy in particular are reportedly
resisting kicking russia out of the
international banking system that's seen
as a nuclear option carrying significant
economic consequences especially for
nations that rely on russian oil europe
sucks on russian gas
like a crackhead on a pipe and how does
a junkie sanction its dealer
it's very very difficult western leaders
insist the swift option is still on the
table but the latest sanctions come too
late for the people of ukraine
jeff semple global news
ahead vladimir putin's grand plan to
restore russia's glory
after taking office in 2000 the russian
president called the collapse of the
soviet union a genuine tragedy in the
greatest geopolitical catastrophe of the
20th century is this invasion of ukraine
one step in his plan to reconstitute the
soviet union eric sorenson looks at
putin's grand plan
few saw it coming to this russia
launching a war on its democratic
neighbor vladimir putin told russian
business leaders he had no option
they've created such security risks we
could not react differently he said
vladimir putin a one-time kgb operative
has long feared the west's threat to
russia's security for 20 years he has
rebuilt or forced compliant
relationships on russia's borders
but ukraine would not comply in 2014
mass protests and unrest ousted the
kremlin-friendly ukrainian leader
putin and russia almost immediately took
over crimea and backed rebel unrest
elsewhere but the risk remained of
ukraine slipping from russia's historic
influence and control that reassertion
of the russian sphere of influence
ukraine is the grand prize everybody
else is like small potatoes ukraine is
strategically crucial to russia's own
sense of security it fears a potential
gateway for nato into the russian
heartland if ukraine becomes a nato
member is that russia's
military capabilities capacity and its
own security
would be at risk
but if russia's military campaign is
successful it could destabilize the west
the target is the stability in europe
and the whole of the international peace
order putin has appealed to russian
patriotism for support
but even at home there are russians who
oppose the invasion risking arrest for
speaking out
the usually pragmatic russian leader has
now played his cards revealing just how
large are his fears and his ambitions
eric sorensen global news toronto
next the worldwide signs of solidarity
with ukraine
a full-scale unprovoked invasion of
ukraine is not something the world can
turn a blind eye to mike armstrong looks
at how people around the globe are
rallying in solidarity with ukraine
it is a simple gesture small and
probably not even noticed by most
passing by but city hall in canada's
capital on this day is flying the blue
and yellow flag of ukraine
there have been protests for weeks
what's going on now is different it's no
longer about pressuring vladimir putin
and trying to prevent military action
that's happening rallies like this one
in greece are now about solidarity
there is disappointment sadness anger
fear this woman says
and worry
ukrainians everywhere share that last
one the worry being far from home and
watching from afar is painful we need
help we need someone to support us it's
our land we didn't do anything wrong it
just put in submissions
if the emotions are there and they are
it's all just starting
explosions and the exodus are only the
beginning whether it's people huddled in
bomb shelters or fleeing the country
these stories of sadness are just the
first of many
oh just
shattered shattered not for myself no i
don't care about my safety i just i care
about ukraine
now just because a conflict starts one
way in one place doesn't mean it ends
there europeans know war has a way of
ignoring borders even if that's what's
being fought over
calling on commerce on the show more
starts this man says you don't know
where it's going to go
this chant in moscow is no to war there
are videos of russians protesting their
country's actions those videos also show
many being arrested russian authorities
realizing perhaps that if conflicts
sometimes snowball into something bigger
resistance sometimes does that as well
this is not the russian people's war
this is the kremlin's war and this is
saint petersburg thousands of protesters
took to the streets in a number of
russian cities today saying no to war
and paying a price for it protest is
illegal in russia human rights groups
say more than 1700 people have been
arrested
that is global national for this
thursday thanks for watching
[Music]
you